desperately fleeing the violence
people here want the authorities to step
in
we don't ask for a lot the gang members
have invaded the area we want the police
to go ahead and confront them we're on
our own we have nothing
criminal groups now control about 80
percent of Haiti's Capital portal Prince
United Nations officials have called for
an international Force to support the
Haitian police in their struggle against
the gangs
it was simply the sound of gunfire that
woke us up this morning it was 3 A.M The
Gangs invaded us there was shooting
shooting all over this neighborhood is a
peaceful area all the people in the
surrounding area are peaceful citizens
but this time local residents took
matters into their own hands
with serious consequences
more than a dozen suspected gang members
were stoned and burned alive images that
are too graphic to show
the police had seized the vehicle and
confiscated weapons but haven't
explained how a crowd of people managed
to kill their men
if the gangs come to invade us we will
defend ourselves we have our own weapons
we have our machetes we will not run
away mothers who want to protect their
children can send them elsewhere
gangs fight to control territory in
Haiti the nation has been in a spiral
since the assassination of President
juvenile mois in 2021. civilians caught
between a lack of Law and Order and
criminal gangs are sometimes better
armed than the police
the United Nations has warned violence
in the capital has reached levels
comparable to countries at War
assadbek al-jazeera
still ahead on Al Jazeera the bodies of
more cult members